does the screenwriter really have to
live in Los Angeles it depends if the
screenwriter wants to write for
television the answer as much as people
hate to hear it is yes
television is a all-hands-on-deck kind
of business so you really do have to be
here for a writer to get staffed for a
writer to sell a pilot there's going to
be an obscene amount of meetings that
precede that there's an obscene amount
of networking so a writer really does
need to be here for television unless
they are brought in by their agent their
manager just to sell a pilot and they're
able to come in for weeks at a time for
meetings that's that if you want to
staff on television you have to be here
people are not going to take a chance
that you'll make the move once you get
the job and they're going to give more
consideration to writers who are
available to walk into the room in two
days I can tell you most of my writers
who've gotten staffed for the first time
on a show usually got the word five or
six days before it's not one of those
things that you know weeks and weeks and
months in advance you hope you have
suspicions you're told by the showrunner
but you don't have your paperwork in
hand until a few days before the room
opens and so you have to be available to
not only be in the room when the room
opens but also network executives want
to meet with you it wasn't expected but
here they are it's now 10 o'clock on a
Wednesday morning and they want you in
at 3:00 and if you can't make it you
don't have the job so you have to be
available for all of those things I find
that showrunners and executive producers
are less willing to take a chance on
writers that they don't know to be
available in that fashion now for film
writers I find the situation's very
different as a film writer you can be
anywhere in the country the world is a
little bit more difficult because we do
want you to be available for meetings be
available quickly so I do find that a
lot of people are a bit more forgiving
as far as geography is concerned for
feature writers the most important thing
about living in Los Angeles is that it's
a sign of your commitment to this career
I work with a great feature writer who
lives in Colorado who Matt a manager
wanted to sign him and the manager knew
that we had worked together and so he
called me and he said how do I know this
guy is really serious he's in Colorado
and so I had to step in
say no no I promise I swear I've read
more than one piece this writer this is
the career this is what he's doing it's
not a hobby so the move to Los Angeles
is not so much for availability on the
film side even though that is important
so I don't want to discount that you
have opportunities to network and meet
and not only meet executives but meet
your class of writers but it is an
important sign of commitment to this is
the thing that I want it is not a hobby
it is not a thing that might or might
not turn out to be it's something that I
am banking on you know a lot of people
talk about coming to Los Angeles because
this is where movies and television are
made and if this is what you want to be
a part of if you can you should get here
now as a mother of two and a wife I
certainly understand that if my life was
elsewhere and I wanted to be a writer
maybe moving is not that available to me
if that is indeed the scenario then the
writing has to be that much stronger so
that it does get noticed through the
surer channels of the big big contests
that if you're a feature writer you want
to get to semi finalists in the nickel
fellowship not necessarily just the
quarter finalist you want to really have
your work surface in a way that it
becomes undeniable and undeniable is a
word that you're going to hear me say a
lot because it's a big key term for the
industry work that is undeniable writers
who are undeniable that's who the
industry wants to work with so let's
take a hypothetical and tell me if this
might work suppose I'm a writer I live
in the Midwest and I have a relative or
a friend that has an LA address and so
I'm telling these network executives oh
I'm in LA and I'm trying to make it work
and squeak by can that really happen
suppose I say yeah I live in LA I can I
can what time you need me there I take a
flight how realistic is that I'm going
to be able to keep that up until I'm
hired it's possible not probable I've
gotten calls for my writers by somebody
saying hey you work with such-and-such
right it's Friday it's 11 o'clock I want
this person in my office at 2:00 mmm I
want to sign them before the weekends
over get them over here and if you say
when they can't do it that becomes a
problem Wow and also there's an issue of
honesty right you want to be as honest
as possible now I have a good friend
who's in Seattle who is a television
feature writer who comes down on a
regular basis and takes meetings I have
writers in New York New York I do find
to be an advantageous location because
the industry travels to it a lot so
there are opportunity to meet with
potential your agent or your manager
when they're visiting New York you know
you want to be as honest as you can
about it while being entirely available
so the thing is to say I'm in Seattle if
you let me know by 8 o'clock in the
morning I can be there too hmm okay
right so yeah aside from the honesty
part still being able to travel and
making it work and being able to move
here if you get the job probably sounds
like it wouldn't work
well the thing is that writers who are
remote to Los Angeles should expect
regular trips to Los Angeles at their
own expense initially before the writer
is repped it's going to be to come out
here to potentially attend conferences
or classes or events start to get to
know their writing class then when they
when they are read to come to meet their
reps and then start going out on general
meetings that their rep sets up for them
so you know what I have writers coming
in from the East Coast
sometimes I don't even get to see them
because they're literally booked from
Monday morning at nine o'clock in the
morning all the way through to Friday at
5:00 p.m. sometimes into the weekend
with back-to-back meetings and that's
something that any writer who's not in
Los Angeles should expect to take on
should their material hit and that's
really what we want right because the
way that a writer breaks today is not
quite as linear as write a script sell
the script get the money it's write the
script use the script to introduce you
to Los Angeles introduce you to the
industry in the context of general
meetings so that's where the writer will
get to go out on a lot of generals meet
with a lot of people and for that you
certainly want to be able to do that do
that consistently sometimes do it every
few months you know when things get
really really hot then potentially do it
every month those are the things that a
writer needs to be able to deliver on
and agents and managers tend to look for
those red flags that signal whether or
not the writer is going to be available
to be in Los Angeles as much as it's
going to be required in order for them
to get a career off the ground
okay another hypothetical and that is
someone has a family trip and they're
going to come to LA and they want to get
a feel of the landscape they plan to
be pitching scripts they may even come
and move out here what would you say is
a good self tour for them well I always
tell writers who come into town from
another location occasional have a
writer from Australia saying I want to
come to LA with a family or without but
come to Los Angeles how do I do it best
the way that I usually advise writers to
do it is to plan their trip around an
event so they have a natural destination
in which they can go they can meet other
writers they can potentially meet
industry people so whether you are
coming for one of the big pitch events
that take place in the summer or you're
coming for a conference like the
produced by conference that puts you
face-to-face with the industry you want
to plan a visit around that and then
look for other networking events that
are happening around that get to know
the landscape that way but have those
anchoring events that that really inform
your visit is supposed to show up and go
I'm here anybody say yeah so I like to
have visits anchored by events as many
as possible and then you know usually
the the good thing about Los Angeles is
that we do have networking events that
are happening all the time so in any
given week you can find is a Thursday
night social you can go to that happens
once a month we have script writers
network that has Friday night drinks we
have blacklist that puts on event so
final draft does all of these
organizations put on networking and
socializing events for writers as well
as what happens regularly at the WJ
foundation that puts on great panels and
the list goes on and on so you really
want to anchor your trip with an event
and then find networking events around
those so that you can start to get to
know not only executives that you want
to work with agents and managers you'd
like to have rep you but other writers
who are themselves breaking in who may
have amassed a little bit more
information that you have so fun so far
and really help you learn the lay of the
land
you